the Joe Rogan experience woke yeah it's
just the religion it's there they're
part of the religion and we really
should start referring to it as a
religion we should but then that there
would be some push Church of woke hey
they get tax-free status to show up at
the woke Cathedral yeah and and they've
got all your money to transgender people
or whatever they've got their high
priests I mean yes they do they've got
their you know their Saints their
canonized certain people they've been
all of the hallmarks you know I just
think I my only I mean I'd have
described it in those terms and I have
done today but but to what is that
really effective way to challenge it as
in is that isn't that just gonna get
people's backs up isn't that gonna keep
it a little bit everything you say about
it will get people's backs up but I
think at least it'll make people
understand that there are some
fundamental patterns and human behavior
that have existed from the beginning of
time yeah people like structure and
they're like they like knowing where the
rules are because life in itself is too
open-ended there's too much existential
angst there's too many confusing
questions that can't be answered there's
so much going on in life itself that if
you have a very rigid ideology whether
it is about a holy creator or whether
it's about the fundamental aspects of
society that are that are unfair yeah
and need to be rallied against whether
it's woke ideology or whether it's you
know fill in the blank whatever other
ideology I just wish I could talk to
them more but they refused to talk to me
this is Wow they don't wanna be I mean
you could talk to some the same way that
Meghan Phelps talked to her husband
online you could talk to the ones that
are thinking maybe this is [ __ ] and
some of them do think it's [ __ ] and
I know some of them that have broken
free ya know some former woke people
that have woken up I but I also get a
lot of messages from people saying I
really like the jokes you're telling but
I will never retreat them dad - yeah I
can't say it but they also want to keep
their job you know they don't want
anybody harassing their okay there's a
lot of that all right a lot of people
that just want to keep this job well
maybe then when I was talking about the
tipping point and when does it end maybe
it's when more people who are willing to
be honest about their skepticism about
the whole thing
maybe think that's coming I think I
think is even though thing people are
being very rabid
I think more people are going what in
the [ __ ] they are happy they say and
it's the language policing that gets so
annoying words are not the problem folks
it's actual prejudice that's the problem
cause you know I mean whatever it is
whatever it is it's we've got this issue
with telling other people what to do
yeah I've got this issue with wanting
people to comply with the standards of
behavior that we are adhering to well
that's what I terrifies me about it is
the sheer certainty of it when you get
into a conversation when in the rare
occasions where someone from the work
movement will will talk to me it's like
they've it's never crossed their mind
that they could be wrong that it's just
not in their realm of existence that
they would even possibly think for a
second maybe I've got this a bit wrong
and that to me is a horrible I I don't
know how you challenge that even you
know you can't just like you can't
challenge someone who's a believer in
the Westboro Baptist yeah but really
does one walk around those God hates
[ __ ] find their way out and they
eventually they they know from - but not
many Megan can't even talk to her mom
really didn't they talk to her they even
turned on the leader didn't they turned
on Fred oh he died okay did they turn on
him after he died said he he was a
sinner as well I think they probably
that's probably why they think he died
[ __ ] nuts
he was truly pure I would have kept him
alive and he was probably thinking about
homos you know who knows okay okay at
least they're consistent I mean they
they are hateful hateful Eakins as they
are hate pretty consistent you know they
they don't twist that they are literally
interpreting the Bible as it said like
in a really scary way yeah very scary
way and the fact that it justifies some
pretty horrific actions I mean q-max
your soldier if your son was a soldier
and your son got shot down yeah and
you're at the funeral and these guys are
standing in front of the building where
you're having the service and they're
saying the reason why your son dies cuz
there's a bunch of people out there that
are in love with other men yeah having
sex with men and so this is the reason
why and they're gonna hold up these
giant placards it's horrible it's
[ __ ] crazy that's one of the that's
one of the examples that really gets
me that challenges me in so far as my
free speech yeah that's position because
I just I thought there's something it's
so appalling and upsetting when you see
that sort of thing but then do I can't I
can't say that I want to live in a
society where people aren't allowed to
protest right it's you can see it's like
everything else in human nature it's
messy and those woke people need to
understand that it's messy - yeah life
is messy you can't you can't get 100%
compliance from people and if you want
that you're a bully yeah you know you're
being mean
you can't they're not gonna do it and
you're not right you're not right
especially you're definitely not right
if you're not willing to debate people
on this idea so you don't even know if
you're right that's why Obama was saying
was anybody who said that you know
people aren't perfect any perfect yes it
was brilliant and then straight after he
said it there was an article in The New
York Times that said basically what a
Boomer thing to say that was what the
responses are what a boot right it's a
boot like wow that's well serious that's
not a serious response to quite a
nuanced point is it no I think every
generation thinks they're gonna be the
ones to change the world yeah you know I
mean that that's an issue as well I mean
every generation yet comes along thinks
that they have the answers that their
parents didn't have I see signs though
that the younger generation said what
generations ed or Z you'd say like are
reacting against the millennial
generation and there's there's there is
that's probably where the hope lies
isn't yes because actually the
Millennials are getting old now and yes
and the those ideas are getting a bit
out out of and the Millennials are gonna
have to pay their bills right the bills
are coming yeah and when the bills are
coming like [ __ ] yeah I got it handsome
yeah and then they realize other people
aren't working as hard and like hey what
socialism is great but I'd like you to
work Mike
yeah no he'll be destroyed by the
realities of a capitalist society yeah I
mean ultimately the realities of life
are show me a young man who is not a
liberal and I'll show you a man with no
heart right show me an old man who's not
conservative and I'll show you a man
with no brain yep or Bernie Sanders you
just get stuck to his guns a lot of
people develop bills and Andrea and they
see that there's a lot of people that
don't want to work hard and there's they
make excuse
four things when the reality is their
own behavior that's been holding them
back and there's there's so many
realities that are uncomfortable that we
have to address as we get older in life
and we realize how many people have
fallen into these classical pitfalls and
maybe our parents that told us about but
we thought we knew better
[Applause]